الكوريتان اتهامات متبادله بالاستفزاز
وتصعيدهم يحاكي حربا مؤجله بالصواريخ
والبيانات عبرت بيونج يونج عن غضبها من
التدريبات العسكريه المشتركه غير بعيد
عنها
واشنطن رسميا انتهت عاصفه اليقظه السبت بد
ان الغبار الذي سببته لن ينقشع قريبا
كوريا الشماليه سترد على العدو كما ورد
حرفيا في بيان هيئه الاركان قالت ان تجارب
الصواريخ البالستيه الاخيره هي اجابه
واضحه لورشه الرسول بشان تدريبات الاسبوع
الماضي وحذرت من انه كل ما تواصلت تحركات
العسكريه لاستفزازيه فان الجيش الشعبي
الكوري سيواجههم بمزيد من الدقه والقسوه
وشهادههم خلال الايام الماضيه بعشرات
الصواريخ التي اطلقت ومنها صاروخ باريستي
عبر للقارات اثر الرعبا وتساؤلات كوريا
الجنوبيه هي التي قدمت تفاصيل عنه بلغ
مذاه نحو 760 كلم وارتفاعه اكثر من 1900
كم بسرعه 15 مره تحضر واشنطن وصول من ان
عمليات اطلاق الصواريخ قد تكون تمهيدا
لتجربه النوويه جديده ستكون السابعه في
تاريخ كوريا الشماليه استدعى الامر
استنفارا وعلى اكثر من صعيد لدى خصمك يومك
رومانسي
اتصال على
العمل على رساله حاسمه وموحده بشان
استفزازات كوريا الشماليه
وهذا الاستعراض للاسطول البحريه اليابانيه
الدولي قد يكون احدى تلك الرسائل الحدث هو
الاول من نوعه منذ سبع سنوات وشاركت فيه
12 دوله
رئيس الوزراء الياباني نبره مزج فيها
التحذير بالتحديد قال لك الشده انه ينبغي
لاستعداد لعصر يظهر فيه لاعبون يخالفون
القواعد ويستخدمون القوه والتهديدات
لتدمير السلام والامن في دول اخرى
وعدم تسريع المناقشات الجاريه بشان ما هو
مطلوب للدفاع عن شعبه من خلاله ابقاء كل
الخيارات مطروحه خيار تهدئه النفوس
والجيوش هو الابعد في المنطقه هذه الايام